he's Jerry West the hall-of-famer
clipper consultant and of course former
consultant with the Warriors and former
GM of the LA Lakers good morning Jerry
how are you good morning Dan how are you
today I'm doing great how was the
hunting trip in West Virginia well it's
really fun I got a chance to see some
friends back there and the weather was
even those little chilly it was it was
beautiful this time of year back there
so back there for two three days and got
a chance my son was there so we had a
Grilli good time did you get to watch
the Clippers come back against the
Warriors I sure did sure it was crazy
how do you explain that well there's
some things are not explainable what I
think I think sometimes sports is
probably in many ways if you can
recapture some of the dramatic things
have happened in sports over the years
some of the really iconic moments this
had this had to be one of them and for a
reason you know when they introduced the
Warriors team you say oh my gosh you
know there's four five all-stars out
there and then they introduced a clipper
team which doesn't get a lot of love in
terms of special players you almost
think oh my gosh how can they compete
well they can compete and they do
compete and they've done some things
this year have been simply amazing and
really have to get a lot of credit to
our coaching staff you know they've got
these guys in a place where they think
they can beat anyone regardless of what
people say about odds there they just
compete and it's fun to watch and fun be
part of it really is I think there was a
quote from Patrick Beverley who after
Tobias Harris was traded went to
management said are we tanking and then
management said no did did that happen
yes he did a lot of players a lot of
players question you know a lot of
things that are done and we have a very
open group of people we're working with
Lawrence Franks has been really fun he's
a good guy doesn't take himself real
seriously but he is one of the
hardest-working people
and I think all the stuff that was done
over there was pretty well thought out
it's it's a this organization does some
really really good things behind the
scenes a lot of meetings a lot of
studying for the future well you know
what what can we position due to
position ourselves better going forward
and everyone talks about free agency
free agency to me is something that you
wait and see if people want to go
somewhere we get we got a lot of assets
all that trade and and the people we
traded tobias bond and mike scott every
one of those guys were as nice as
professional as I had ever met in my
life
they are fantastic people and this is
what has made this place special all
these players there's no there's not one
star on this team there's a bunch of
people that are really good players that
don't get a lot of credit but the
biggest thing is they just they're just
great people if you're around them it's
you feel like you're family I've never
seen a team that has no hidden agendas
at all
it's just this is just fantastic to
watch and and be part of you have talked
to me numerous times about it was so
hard to watch the Lakers when you were
the GM are you able to watch the
Clippers as a consultant is it different
oh it's completely different you know I
think at those times Dan you know you're
so intimately involved and we didn't
have tons of people working for us and
it was you just feels so much part of it
and you're there every day I'm not there
every day but you know I have
communicate with these people I go over
there frequently and and you know
interact with the people team the
coaches the staff over there
and when you're you know making
decisions then it's sometimes it's not a
lot of fun you're a judge jury
executioner you're you're subjected to a
lot of kind of mean things that people
say about you but it's what the NBA has
become today but this place I will give
credit to you owner Steve Ballmer this
is one of the nicest men I have ever
been around in my life he is an
incredible competitor and you know what
in heritage a franchise led by Don
sterling
you know you only hoped that he was
gonna be better but he's exceeded that
in terms of who he is as a person he's
just a fantastic person and be around
him he is like he's brunettes made Jerry
Buss a little bit except of course he's
a lot richer but he's just kind of a
people person and he loves people if
you're around him you would not know you
would not know anything about him you
say oh my gosh this is one of nicest
people reroute and I think this
organization reflects that and si
Lawrence Franks I couldn't get it give
enough credit to he just he's really
assembled some great people over there
and obviously some people would like to
take some of those people but he's he
just done a great job and sets a tone we
just had a group of great staff it's
been a lot of fun for me he's Jerry West
the hall-of-famer joining us Dan Patrick
show we had the comedian Jeff Garlin on
and he's now our new NBA insider he said
he sat next to you at a clipper game and
Steve Ballmer and he said hey I got the
inside scoop that Jerry West loves Jama
rant and maybe he would be the best
player in the draft so do you uh do you
want to confirm or deny what the NBA
Insider Jeff Garlin said about your love
of JAMA Rand well you know I think in
today's game you have to look at players
that I think it played players that
translate their games translate to what
is the NBA obviously you know the two
players out there they're gonna get a
whole lot of attention
Zion Williams and my goodness he's like
he's like a human highlight film he's
gonna fill the arenas every night but
every once in a while
you know you see a unique another unique
player who did not get a lot of
attention until way during the year but
he is really a special player I think I
love him
you know he's he's a highlight film
himself along with it was I am but
didn't get as much publicity I think
both of them are great great prospects
and you know when you look at the needs
of teams what does most people what are
most people looking forward to start
with they're looking for a leader and
sometimes a leader is harder to find
than a spectacular player like like as I
am
as I say either one of them either one
of them what on any team anyone either
anyone would love to have those two guys
I just think there can't miss prospects
and with all the publicity Zions god if
you've been around him oh my gosh this
is this is woman nicest people you've
ever seen in your life he's so grounded
and he's gonna appeal oh my goodness
whoever gets him sellouts every night on
the road so else every night and I think
they're [ __ ] kid even though he's he's
going to probably take a little bit of
time I think he's gonna be as special as
anyone in this draft if you had the
number one pick you had to choose who
would you take well you know as I say I
think it depends on the team but I don't
know how I could pass Diane Williamson
I really don't it would be it would be
Oh like passing Michael Jordan in the
draft I think and we want to always go
well who's he remind you of and a lot of
times you'll find comparisons I don't
know whose eye on what who was I on
Williamson before his eye on Williamson
no one I've never seen a body that big
that quick react the way it does he has
got incredible balance his ability to
avoid charges and in college that's a
huge it's a hard thing to do he just he
just didn't he has the ability to do
that but his his I think the thing that
makes him he's just like when he walk
when he does something on the court oh
my everyone now will be on the edge of
their seats when they when he's gonna
run watch him play to see what he's
gonna do next but oh my goodness he's
under watch and his game is gonna work
very well in today's modern NBA game
I've never seen as I said I've never
seen a body jump the second jump is
quicker quicker than the first one
he's a remarkable he's a remarkable
talent but he has appear also as a
basketball player this is not just
someone who plays on a trampoline he's
he's really good what was your reaction
when magic stepped down in one I was
really surprised you know I've always
had the greatest affection for him you
know when you're around someone that has
led a team the way he does did here when
he was with the Lakers and
also going to his retirement thing was
which was probably the most difficult
thing I've ever had to deal with
personally because you weren't really
concerned about basketball I think the
whole Laker organization mentioned that
time wasn't very big that no one was
concentrating on basketball it took
about two weeks for people to get back
into I guess the swing of things that
you know where we going from here but I
was honestly I was shocked I thought I
thought he was you know his voice for an
organization like that very very
important love for people have him in
lausanne tier was surprising to me yeah
yeah I think it's still surprising that
we're trying to figure out what would
happen there in look I know you get you
know drawn back into the vortex that is
the Lakers but I I just out of respect
for what you meant to that organization
even Shaq saying you know they need to
bring you back and I said I think I
think Jerry's having fun with the
Clippers I don't know why I would put
him you know persecute him and put him
back into the Lakers organization right
now well you know as I say anything
that's an iconic brand today anything
that has been around and has had a
much-loved and effect on this city as
the Lakers in today's world it's an easy
target it really is and when people you
know talk about you know where they're
gone they're going to win a championship
that puts a lot of pressure on a bunch
of guys that play together but you know
they had tons of injuries this year my
goodness it wasn't you know you can't
injury to part of the game but they went
when they happen to people that are
important to your team and the people
that you expect to lead it just puts
them in a terrible place and obviously
all the social media people you know
attacking people they have some really
nice people over there and my son works
there and I know and when he and I
talked he it pains him to see you know
some of the stuff is written in many
cases it's not it's not fair but people
are going to hold them to a higher level
as with the New York Yankees the New
England Patriots these iconic brands
they're susceptible to that and it's
just not it doesn't seem quite fair
it really doesn't now you're giving
credit is convincing KD to join the
Warriors well that's not true that's not
true I get a lot of credit which I don't
deserve me honest with your buddy Dan
you know to say the warriors as I say
when I see him introduced they're lying
if I say myself my god what a great job
that organization which I was part of
for for a while has put together up
there and again there's always going to
be criticism directed at players and
everything and had to say I was there
when Kevin was there he's a very very
he's a terrific person but anyway I I'm
not going to be talking about the
Warriors I'm just hoping the Clippers
can make this a very respected
respectable series and hopefully you
know if they lose a game like they did
the other night people are gonna go
crazy but you can't you this Ling
they're 440 people playing in NBA and
when you want to NBA today the one of
the things I think is really interesting
everyone there is competitive everyone
there is a good player and there's
different degrees of players and you
just can't discount the fact this
clipper team this year has done that
more than once they've done three times
already but in the playoff when things
are highlighted there's going to be more
talk so it's been you know it's been fun
to watch and hopefully Thursday night
we'll have a lot of fans and obviously
there's gonna be tons of warrior fans
but I think I think the thing that makes
it kind of interesting the ownership for
the Warriors you know I had a great
relationship with those people up there
and now it's just fund competition is
fun if you don't like competition you
better not be in this business how would
you do against Patrick Beverley in your
playing days I probably bring a handgun
you know he's a mate he's amazing I you
don't want it actually you really have
those kind of players make you play
better I truly believe they make you
play better he's not afraid
dan he's not afraid of anything and he's
and he's one of the greatest people if
you're around him you walk away and say
oh my god what a great guy he just he's
special and to me he's one of the most
valuable players in the league I I would
if I were in a foxhole and there was two
hundred people out there trying to kill
you he would be the one I'd want to be
in there with he is just he's fearless
and my gosh he is fearless and he is
unbelievably the valuable and our
players really look up to him and he
listen and you know he some of the stuff
he does out there he's irritating and if
you get caught up in that but he also is
a good player that's where people don't
you know they just look at him moment
he's an irritant hey no he's really good
if he doesn't score a point he's got a
so valuable to the Clippers it's great
to catch up with you and birthday coming
up in May right oh my goodness yes a lot
of them dance
I don't celebrate them as so many now I
don't know I don't celebrate him you and
I can go out and have a birthday dinner
for all right that's awesome hey you
know the Clippers as I said to Doc
Rivers a couple of weeks ago I loved
watching him because they never quit and
that says a lot to the people who were
behind the scenes too who brought in
these players who you may not know him
but man I love when they take the floor
because that's there's no quit in them
and that's reflective I think of the
people who brought him in so credit to
you and Doc and you know Steve Ballmer
as well but it's always great to talk
about it really has a doc and Lawrence
Frank have been oh my gosh they've done
just a fantastic job and it's it's fun
to see how people react when they're
around me even though they don't get a
lull of doctors but Lawrence Lawrence
doesn't get enough love that's for sure
well good to talk to you and thanks
again there's always cheering any time -
and my best to you thanks Jerry West
Clippers advisor for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app